[MUSIC PLAYING]
KATHARINA PROBST: Hi.
I'm Katherine Probst.
I am a tech lead and manager on
the Google Compute Engine team.
Why don't you
introduce yourselves?
SARAH NYQUIST: Hi,
I'm Sarah, and I
am an intern on the Google
Compute Engine Team.
ASHLIE MARTINEZ: I'm
Ashlie, and I'm also
an intern on the
Compute Engine team.
KATHARINA PROBST: And we're
joined here today by Ryan.
Why don't you introduce
yourself, too.
RYAN COLEMAN: Hi.
I'm Ryan Coleman,
product manager
for the Puppet Forge
at Puppet Labs.
KATHARINA PROBST: Excellent.
So today we're going to
talk a little bit about how
Google Compute Engine
and Puppet Labs
can actually work together
to make great things happen.
We want to jump right
in and show you a demo,
and Sarah will describe a little
bit what the demo will do.
SARAH NYQUIST: So
in this demo, we're
going to create four
Google Compute Engine
instances with Puppet.
And we're going to install
Apache on them, which
will make web pages
for each of them,
and it will have a load balancer
that will allow HTTP traffic
to go between those web pages.
KATHARINA PROBST: OK.
Let's do it.
ASHLIE MARTINEZ: So
to start off with,
we're going to do puppet
cert list -all on our master
node that has Puppet
Enterprise installed on it.
And as you can see, there's
no managed Puppet nodes
on this master.
So now that we know
there's no managed nodes,
we're going to apply
our manifest file.
And what our manifest
is going to do
is it's going to
create persistent disks
and instances-- virtual
machines in Google Compute
Engine-- and those
virtual machines
are going to have Puppet
installed on them,
as well as Apache.
We're also going to create
a forwarding rule so that we
can direct traffic
to our new instances,
and a load balancer that will
direct all the traffic that we
point at the forwarding rule
across those four instances.
KATHARINA PROBST: Great.
So let's take a little bit of
a look at the manifest itself,
and maybe Ryan can help walk
us through a little bit of what
this does.
RYAN COLEMAN: Thank you.
So what we're looking at here
is Puppet's language, the Puppet
DSL.
And Puppet is all about managing
the end state of a machine
that you want to manage.
So you're not
setting up a script
in terms of actions that
you'd like to complete.
You're telling Puppet how
you would like the system
to be configured
at the end the day,
and Puppet takes care of
all the details in between.
So Puppet can manage everything
at the very atomic level,
whether it's a file
that you're managing
on your machine, a
service that you'd
like enabled, a package
you'd like installed.
And that translates to Google
Compute Engine module as well.
And so what we're
using here for our demo
is several resources that
describe a firewall that I'd
like to provision, a
health check, target
pool, and forwarding rule
that make up the load
balancer we're
using for the demo.
And then further
down on the page,
we actually have the Google
Compute disk and instances
that are running up it
and running our operating
systems to provide the demo.
And so this is a very readable,
executable documentation
that you can hand
to someone else
to describe exactly how things
are going to be configured
when Puppet gets a hold of it.
We've managed the Puppet Forge
in Google Compute Engine,
and we, in fact, use this module
to describe how the Puppet
Forge instances are configured.
And we use the Google
Compute load balancer
to split traffic
between different zones.
And so we can hand
this to someone
who gets started on
our team, and they
can take a look at
instances and disks
and resources that look
just like this, describing
how the Puppet
Forge is deployed.
And then they can go
down a level deeper
and see how the
service is managed
at the very high level and
all the way down to the ground
on the individual
units that we're
managing on a Puppet node.
And to me, that's
one of the best
things about this combination.
KATHARINA PROBST: Yeah,
that makes perfect sense.
And under the hood, the way
this is implemented, actually,
is it uses Google Compute
Engine's public API.
So anybody can call
the public API,
and it allows you to do things
like you mentioned-- set up
disks, create disks,
create instances, set up
forwarding rules, and so forth.
Let's switch back to the demo
and see how we're doing there.
So as you can see, the
demo is still running.
So let's back up a little bit
and just talk a little bit more
generally.
We've already heard a
little bit about Puppet.
Let's talk a little bit more
about what Google Compute
Engine is and what it does.
I've already mentioned that
we have a public API that
allows you to create
instances and create disks,
so that already
alludes to the fact
that Google Compute Engine
is Google's infrastructure
as a service offering.
So we have compute.
We have storage.
So all of the nodes can have
disks associated with them,
and that is network storage.
We also have things like
networking provisions,
such as the load balancer
that we keep hearing about.
And I'm actually super excited
to talk about the load balancer
because it is very fast,
and it is actually also
consistently fast.
It requires no warm up time.
You don't have to manage
any nodes or anything.
It just works.
You set up your
forwarding rules,
and you start sending
traffic there.
And it can handle
a lot of traffic.
It looks like our demo has
finished, so why don't we
see what we've created now
with Puppet and Google Compute
Engine.
ASHLIE MARTINEZ: So
first, what we have to do
is we have to get the IP
address of our forwarding rule
so that we can actually
send traffic to it.
If we just send traffic
to our instance's IPs,
it won't be balanced across
all of the instances, which
is why we need this IP address.
KATHARINA PROBST: That's right.
So we are going to, as
Ashlie mentioned, we're
going to be sending traffic to
that external IP address that
represents a forwarding
rule, and then
our load balancer that
I keep talking about
will balance the traffic
between the nodes.
And as you can see here,
with our Puppet manifest,
we've actually installed
Apache in a customized web
page on each of the nodes.
And the traffic is
balanced between them,
as you can see it
bouncing around.
Let's switch back to the slides.
And Ryan, why don't you
say a little bit more
about what your
experience has been
in working with Puppet and
Compute Engine together.
RYAN COLEMAN: Yeah, thank you.
So I think that the demo
sort of demonstrates
how these things
get put together.
And whenever you
describe the instances
that you're going to manage
with Google Compute Engine,
we'll automatically build out
either a Puppet open source
or Puppet Enterprise
master and agent
that you can
immediately get started
managing the infrastructure you
want on Google Compute Engine.
KATHARINA PROBST: Excellent.
So if you'd like to find out
more, on this particular slide,
here are some links
that you can follow.
We have a link to the demo where
you can find out a little bit
more of the demo
we've just shown you,
and it should give
you enough information
to actually reproduce
it for yourself.
We have some Docs that give you
a little bit more information
as well.
And then you can go
off and also learn more
about Google Cloud
Platform and Puppet Labs,
and hopefully use
them both together
in a very productive way.
That's it from here today.
So thank you for
watching, and enjoy
using Puppet in
Google Cloud Platform.
Bye.
RYAN COLEMAN: Thank you.